llegamos a directo hay como le venimos
contando este jueves en su discurso ante
el pleno de la asamblea general de
Naciones Unidas el canciller mexicano
Marcelo ebrard en representación del
presidente Andrés Manuel López Obrador
propuso reformar el consejo de seguridad
de Naciones Unidas por eso conectamos
con nuestro corresponsal en México
varios carbonell Mario detalles de ese
plan del gobierno mexicano para reformar
el organismo estrella de Naciones Unidas
para defender la paz internacional
parte de un diagnóstico que hace el
presidente López Obrador en el sentido
de que el consejo de seguridad de la ONU
está paralizado que no logró evitar un
conflicto bélico no está pudiendo frenar
la guerra y tampoco garantizar el acceso
al mercado de granos básicos de
fertilizantes ni la llegada de la ayuda
humanitaria Es por ello que plantea
crear una comitiva internacional
integrada por jefes de gobierno y jefes
de estado entre ellos el Primer Ministro
de la India narendra modi y el Papa
Francisco una especie de Cocos que sea
un canal diplomático que complemente los
ya existentes en aras de llegar a una
solución del conflicto
Aquí también el presidente López Obrador
ha sometido a esta propuesta a distintos
jefes de estado al propio Antonio
Gutiérrez según Marcelo ebrard lo han
sometido a
consideración del jefe del secretario
general de la ONU y están a la espera de
que esto pueda conformarse es este el
proyecto que se tiene desde México Mario
está propuesta de México llega a la
asamblea general de la ONU después de
que en las últimas semanas viéramos al
presidente amlo cargar contra organismos
no solo como como la oea sino como la
oea que hay detrás de esta retórica
Así es lo que al presidente López
Obrador le incomoda un poco es que
organismos de la ONU como la ONU dh
cuestionen el plan que tiene el gobierno
de López Obrador de poner a la guardia
nacional que en teoría Debería ser un
cuerpo civil de seguridad ponerla bajo
el control del ejército de las fuerzas
armadas la ONU derechos humanos así como
la Comisión Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos han señalado que no están de
acuerdo con esta con esta postura con
este proyecto y en ese sentido López
Obrador ha dicho que la ONU y la oea y
la cidh son organismos conservadores y
tendenciosos que cuestan mucho dinero y
que hay que reformarlos porque pues se
prestan a
intereses de este de esta naturaleza